let's keep going we're on problem number
six on page 278 in the data sufficiency
sample questions
so let's see they've drawn a little
figure they say in the figure above
lines k and m are parallel i guess i
better draw lines k and m
so let's see they have line
that's line k
that's line m
and then they have a transversal line
and we've gone over all of this in the
geometry playlist if you might want to
review it and if this looks completely
foreign to you
and so this is line k
this is line m
and they calling this angle right here x
degrees
this line here
is z degrees and then this
angle here that's a line that's an angle
this angle here is y degrees
y degrees and the question is in
question number six in the figure above
if lines k and m are parallel so they're
both parallel
what is the value of x
okay in statement number one
they tell us that y is equal to
100
degrees
so
if y is equal to 120 let me do that in
let me do this one in magenta so this is
based on this is equal to 120. what can
we figure out
well
this y is
y is
supplementary to z right so when they
you know they kind of you add these two
angles together there it's 180 degrees
right because you're completing kind of
a whole half arc or half circle so z
would be 60 degrees
right
z would be 60 degrees
and then you could say that i you know
there's all these words that people use
in geometry class but if you have two
parallel lines and a transversal then
these opposite inside angles are going
to be the same so you know that x is
equal to 60 degrees another way you
could have done it you could say okay if
y is equal to 120 degrees then this
angle then y and this angle right here
are also supplementary right because
they complete this whole arc
so y plus this angle have to be equal to
180. so this angle would also be 60 and
then you use what you learned in
geometry class that you know
corresponding angles on on a transversal
intersecting two parallel lines that
they're also equal so you'd also get to
the same conclusion that x is equal to
60. so either way
statement number one alone is enough to
figure out x now what do they give us
for statement number two and i'll do
that in a different color
statement number two z is equal to 60.
well this actually gives us the same
information as that because if we know
that z is equal to 60 then we know that
y is going to be equal to 120 even if i
never even if the book never told us
this the first time so z equal to 60 is
the same information as y is equal to
120 and so you can make the exact same
arguments as you did for the first one
so actually point number two alone is
also enough to figure out that x is
equal to 60 you actually didn't even
have to figure it out and an important
skill eventually when you're when you're
taking the gmat is to be able to just
look at it and say oh i could figure
that out and then move on instead of
actually having to figure out that x is
equal to 60. but anyway so this one is
either of them alone are sufficient so
that's d
okay problem number seven
problem number seven
what percentage of a group of people are
women with red hair
so women we want women
with red hair
percentage
okay so statement number one
tells us of the women in the group five
percent have red hair
five percent
of women
have
red hair
that alone doesn't tell me what
percentage of the entire group have uh
are are women with red hair because i
don't know how large the whole group is
there could be um you know there could
be i don't know 20 women and there could
be 10 million men
so you know the percentage or there
could be 20 women and no man so that
still doesn't help me with you know what
percentage of women what percentage of
the group are women with red hair
see statement number two
statement number two tells us
where was that of the men in the group
ten percent have red hair so ten percent
of
men have red hair
that's really useless
have red hair
once again i don't know how big the
group is
right i mean you you think about it if i
have uh 20 women then that tells me that
there's one woman with red hair and i
don't know i have 20 women right
but i still don't know how many men
there are right if they're 20 women and
and one has red hair there could be a
million men there could be no man in
which case this answer would turn out
very different what percentage of the
group are women with red hair so both of
these combined are are fairly useless
questions and actually let me let me
draw a little venn diagram because
i think it's it's useful so the entire
group
is both women and men let me
i'll draw a vent of
a then rectangle instead of a so that's
women and men so
some percentage of you know we don't
know how many women there are and how
many men
so this this area right here is women
this is women
that's the number of women
and this is the number of men
and this
first point tells us the five percent of
the women have red hair
so it just tells us that five percent of
this area is red
right which is maybe i don't know i'll
eyeball it like that
and then this says that 10 of the men
have red hair so maybe that area looks
something like that
right so we know the ratio of this to
this box and we know the ratio of this
to this box is 10 percent but we don't
know the ratio of this to the entire
universe because we don't know how many
uh we don't know what the total
we don't know the total population size
is so we'll never be able to figure it
out anyway so that is
that is e all right problem number eight
maybe maybe i missed something but
that's
problem eight
if r and s are positive integers
r is what percent of s
so r
s
positive
integers
and we want to know
r
is what percent of s so essentially we
just want to figure out
what r over s is equal to
right this will give us some decimal and
then you multiply by 100 and you know
the percentage so if you can figure out
this you can figure out the percentage
of what what r is what percentage of s
okay so statement number one
statement number one they tell us that r
is equal to three
fourths
s
well let's just do a little algebraic
manipulation we're just trying to get r
over s so let's divide both sides by s
so you get r
over s is equal to three over four
so there we got it we got the answer
this that was a helpful data point all
we needed was that data point actually
let's see what the second data point
gives us
data point two
divided by s well they they wrote it
like this they wrote it the way you did
in second grade r divided by s is equal
to 75 over 100
well that's just another way of just
writing r over s is equal to 75 over 100
which is exactly the same thing as this
so these are actually you know
equivalent statements almost so each of
them independently are enough to figure
out r over s or what percentage r is of
s
all right problem number
nine
problem number nine
let me draw a line here i don't want to
get too messy
do nine in magenta
is it true that a is greater than b
i sometimes find these uh statements i
don't know slightly humorous
is it true that a is greater than b
anyway all right
all right the the first statement is 2a
is greater than
2b
so i don't know if you remember from
algebra but
you can operate on inequalities the
exact same way you can operate on
equalities or i guess you call them
equations
and you just have to remember that if
you multiply or divide by a negative
number that you have to swap the
inequality sign well luckily in this
case we're we are we are we could divide
both sides by a positive number so if
you're doing if you're multiplying or
dividing by
a positive on both sides you don't have
to change the inequality so just divide
both sides by 2 and you could test that
with numbers just to see why that makes
sense so you divide both sides by 2 and
you get a is greater than b
so that's all we needed we just needed
statement 1. now let's see what
statement 2 does for us
statement two
tells us that
a plus c
is greater than b plus e well once again
this is a we can subtract c from both
sides of this equation or from both
sides of this inequality without
changing the inequality sign right so
you subtract c from both sides and once
again you get a is greater than b so
each of these statements independently
are enough for us to figure out that it
is true that a is greater than b
let's do one more actually i've run out
of chalkboard space so i might as well
just wait until the next video see you
soon